these pills were going to save who
burped Brooke Mueller's life at least
that's what doctors at this East German
hospital told him it was 1989 and Brooke
Mueller was being treated for a chronic
heart problem but the doctors failed to
tell him that the medication had not yet
been officially approved we didn't know
that back in the days of communist East
Germany during the treatment there were
no indications of that no information
information these pills were produced by
a West German drug company called
Sanders many firms tested new drugs in
the former East a new report says some
50,000 people were used as guinea pigs
the East German government was paid hard
currency for its participation but
Western companies profited too he wasn't
as honest as I see the biggest failures
in the formation of an unholy alliance
between drug companies that without
public knowledge conducted studies some
of which could not well have been done
in West Germany the purse honest to
ashwin Conan today big drug companies
often prefer to conduct medical trials
in developing countries and emerging
economies critics of the pharmaceutical
industry say the system is highly
problematic the percent patients
protection and declarations of consent
which are required here and set the bar
quite high those things are less
established their meaning pharmaceutical
testing can be conducted more easily
when an ID for Hardwick of food feared
it seems the situation was similar in
the former East Germany though the drug
industry says the trials were done by
the book now some politicians are
calling for compensation for patients
like who vet Brooke Mueller
you